The Visitor pattern is an example of a behavioral pattern.
And in order to describe the behavior, we use a sequence diagram in this case.
Recall that in the sequence diagram,
each of the columns corresponds to a different object.
The horizontal lines correspond to messages being sent among the objects.
And that time marches down the page.
The first column in the diagram corresponds to the data structure itself.
And it is responsible for sending messages to each of the concrete classes, and
those messages are accept messages passing in whatever visitor we
currently want to implement.
The concrete classes are in the second column.
Their responsibility is for doing the callback.
That is, they are given a visitor as an argument and
they need to pass themselves to the particular visitor operation responsible for
whatever visitor they're currently implementing.
Those are the messages at the top which go from the second column over to
the fourth column and
in the middle of the screen from the third column over to the fourth column.
Finally, in the visitor operation itself in the fourth column,
can make calls back into the elements,
taking advantage of whatever operations those elements provide.